arnaud benedetti rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire
un bon soir nos benedetti merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france comment est-ce
que vous analysez ces manifestations de
soutien à l'afro américain qui a été tué
à minneapolis est ce que c'est
comparable selon vous au delà du racisme
qui est dénoncée aux états unis est-ce
que c'est pas plutôt les inégalités qui
sont dénoncés par ces jeunes
bien évidemment ce n'est en aucun point
comparable si vous voulez là le modèle
le modèle français c'est un modèle
républicain qui est basé sur une
reconnaissance citoyenne et qui exclut
en principe toute forme de
communautarisme
aux etats unis nous avons une société
qui est profondément communautariste et
dont on mesure aujourd'hui à travers un
épisode dramatique qui aujourd'hui si tu
ne une émotion légitime à travers la
planète que ce modèle est un modèle qui
d'une certaine manière ce site des
tensions intercommunautaires
donc il ya vraiment une différence
fondamentale entre eux ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en france est ce qui s'est
passé aux états unis mais la question
qu'est la question essentielle c'est le
lien à la police le lien la police
on voit bien que la relation à la police
depuis maintenant quelques années s'est
quelque peu dégradée
on avait sous l'os ou non nous en 2015
après les attentats une opinion publique
qui massivement soutenez sa police
l'applaudît c'est là un certain nombre
d' enquêtes ont montré que ce lien
c'était d'une certaine manière
émoussé il faut faire très attention
quand on parle quand même de cette
question là globalement évité toute
généralisation
les forces de police font un métier
extrêmement difficile qui est le métier
qui consiste à maintenir l'ordre public
elles sont au contact de ces situations
qui sont en permanence des situations
critiques et en l'occurrence l'ami
grande majorité des policiers exercent
avec un grand professionnalisme leur
mission et vous parler des relations
avec la volée sont à ces images en
direct du stand du champ de mars où il y
a quelques légères tensions entre ces
jeunes et il est policier en fin de
manifestation c'est assez classique
maintenant justement cette relation à la
police a renouvellé d'éthique
est ce que ce n'est pas là la haye la
politique aussi de sécuritaire du
gouvernement qui est en cause la police
finalement exécutée à cette politique
est totalement la police ce n'est qu'un
organe régalien qui est sous l'autorité
du politique soutenu lors du mandé gilet
jaune ce n'était pas la police en tant
que tel qui a été mise en cause c'était
l' usage proportionné ou
disproportionnées qu'on faisait des
forces de l'ordre mais cet usage des
forces de l'ordre il est directement est
lié aux consignes de l'exécutif aux
consignes du politique c'est bien là le
poids est essentielle mais pour en
revenir à ces mouvements aujourd'hui
auquel on assiste en fait on voit bien
qu'il ya aussi derrière ces
mobilisations qui reste quand même il
faut le dire assez faible numériquement
même si elles ont un écho médiatique
il y as derrière ces mobilisations un
certain nombre de groupements politiques
qui d'une certaine façon il faut pas
hésiter à lire instrumentalise la
situation qui est la situation propre
aux états unis pour mener un autre
combat ici en france alors précisé
lequel arnaud benedetti quel combat
serait insensé mené il ya des il ya des
revendications si vous voulez
communautaires qui sont très clairement
exprimée dans un certain nombre de ses
mouvements
on a lu par exemple la ligue de défense
des noirs d'afrique qui était présente
dans le cortège et qui sont des pluies
l'état français le qualifiant de
colonial et de terroristes
il y à un certain nombre de mouvements
proches des salafistes aussi qu'ils
peuvent être présents ont dansé dans ces
mobilisations
donc il faut être très lucide sur
l'instrumentalisation qui existe au sein
de ses mouvements et il y a bien
évidemment des gens qui sont totalement
de jaillir de bons deux fois dans
l'expression de leur colère qui s'agrège
aussi à ses mouvements on le voit sur
ses pancartes la vie des noirs comptent
ces pancartes brandies en france vous
lisiez la situation n'est absolument pas
comparable
il n'y a pas eu d' esclavage en
métropole en tout cas en france ces
jeunes
cette mondialisation finalement de la
colère est ce que on n'a pas tendance à
tout mélanger
ou est ce que c'est le cas à cause de la
mondialisation et des images notamment
et des séries télévisées
il ya si vous voulez la culture de
l'instant immédiat et de l'émotion qui
aujourd'hui se virent à lisa l'échelle
de la nanoseconde à l'ensemble de la
planète et qui ne nous permettrait
simplement pas d'avoir le recul
indispensable pour bien comprendre ce
qui se passe mais il ya quelque chose
in fine et d'assez à la fois préoccupant
dans dans ces moments c'est que on voit
bien que les sociétés sont sous tension
et c'est ce que finalement laisse
apparaître ce type de mobilisation
on est dans des sociétés de plus en plus
crack tué facturés par nom ou la commune
autorisation des liens finalement
devient d'une certaine façon une forme
de règles voire d'expression politique
qui remet en cause profondément le
modèle qui est le modèle républicain
français qui est un modèle
d'indifférenciation alors bien
évidemment l'indifférenciation c'est des
principes ensuite la l'application de
cette indifférenciation c'est autre
chose mais semblablement on sait très
bien qu'il existe des discriminations
qu'il faut combattre et qui existent
mais en l'occurrence il ya derrière
encore une fois certaines de ces
mobilisations une revendication qui est
finalement plus
différentialiste que celle d'un accès à
une citoyenneté universelle là le modèle
républicain français c'est quand même la
citoyenneté universelle est ce qu'il
n'ya pas non plus un effet post
confinement le fait de braver les
interdictions de manifester est ce que
il y a une envie aussi de contester vous
disiez à cause de ces mois de
confinement que les français ont suivi
probablement il y a en tout cas l'envi
de retrouver une vie sociale et une vie
politique démocratique qui je puisse à
nouveau ce est exprimée à travers un
certain nombre de mobilisation on sait
tendre a néanmoins que qui est
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
responsables politiques long long long
long observé que alors que nous sommes
dans une situation de déconfinement et
où on est encore sous le coup de
l'urgence sanitaire que ces
mobilisations puisse se tenir elles sont
certes interdite mais manifestement elle
se tienne on voit bien que les pouvoirs
publics souhaitent vraisemblablement
évité toute crispation supplémentaires
dans une dans un contexte politique et
social qui s'annonce par ailleurs tendu
sur d'autres sur d'autres fronts et on
en reparlera merci beaucoup arnaud venez
vexé pour votre avis